COREY: Hey, how's it going, man?
JOHN: OK.
How are you?
- Good.
What do we got?
I got something you're
not going to believe.
I've got a plaster impression
of Joe DiMaggio's feet,
and I've got them right here.
COREY: OK.
So Joe DiMaggio's feet, huh?
JOHN: Joe DiMaggio's feet.
That's a bad case
of athlete's foot.
[laughing]
I came down to the pawn shop to
sell a plaster cast impression
of Joe DiMaggio's feet that
were credited with saving
his baseball career.
I'm a fan of Joe DiMaggio
because he was an amazing guy.
I'm looking for $10,000.
That seemed to be a very recent
price, considering the, uh,
uniqueness and
historical significance.
COREY: Tell me the
story behind it
here, because it's kind of
weird that you have his feet.
JOHN: My uncle was
his foot doctor,
and he created these casts
to develop inserts for Joe
DiMaggio's baseball
shoes that would
relieve the bone
spurs that almost
ended Joe DiMaggio's career.
COREY: Now, was this
before the streak or after?
JOHN: This is after the streak.
CHUMLEE: What streak
are you talking about?
Joe DiMaggio-- I mean, it's
considered one of the last,
like, unbreakable
records there is.
I mean, he went,
uh, 56 games and got
a hit in every single game.
CHUMLEE: Wow.
That's impressive.
COREY: During the
course of that streak,
his batting average
was, like, over .400.
I mean, the guy was one of
the best baseball players
to ever live.
DiMaggio helped the Yankees
win nine World Series titles,
and in 1955 he was elected
to the Baseball Hall of Fame.
The man is a true
baseball legend.
Do you mind if I
take a look at them?
JOHN: No, go ahead.
COREY: Now is that supposed
to be his signature there?
JOHN: That is his signature.
COREY: OK.
How much do you want for them?
JOHN: I'm looking
to get $10,000.
COREY: OK.
Um, I just never even
heard of plaster casts
of some guy's feet before.
I just don't know what
they could be worth, man.
I'll tell you what.
Let me have a buddy of mine come
down and take a look at them
for me.
Because the problem
with one-of-a-kind
items is sometimes they're
only worth money to one person.
[laughs]
- OK.
Great.
I'll be right back, all right?
JOHN: Thanks.
I welcome expert opinion
because I've done my research,
and it would be disappointing if
he believed the value of these
were less than my asking price.
That would be disappointing.
COREY: The guy was a legend.
And I know there's a huge
market for his memorabilia,
but this is such
an unusual item,
I have no idea what it's worth.
So I called Jeremy in to
come down and check it out.
JEREMY: Yeah, I got to say, man.
In all the years you guys
have been calling me in,
I've seen some
extraordinary things,
but this is by far the wildest.
It's not every day
that you see plaster
molds of arguably the best
player during his generation.
When he joined the New
York Yankees in 1936,
you know, he batted
right behind Lou Gehrig.
And, you know, right
away he just made such
a big impact with the club.
Maybe next to Willie Mays,
he's the best center fielder
in the history of baseball.
Joe DiMaggio is one of
those few names that
has really transcended
generations, along
with Mickey Mantle, Babe Ruth.
He was a 13-time
all-star, won nine
World Series
championships, and only
Yogi Berra has more than him.
COREY: So what do you think?
Well, when Joe joined the
Yankees, he had bad knees.
And then over his career,
just after he achieved so much
stardom on and off
the field between,
you know, knocking in
runs for the Yankees
and winning championships to,
you know, marrying, you know,
a Hollywood goddess,
Marilyn Monroe, you know,
every single thing that Joe
did was known by the public.
Late in his career, his
feet were a big problem.
And, um, ultimately
a lot of people
think that it was his feet
that caused him to retire
following the 1951 season.
COREY: OK.
Here's my big thing.
I-- it's a weird item for me.
JEREMY: No doubt.
COREY: Um, what do you
think they're worth?
JEREMY: Well, we're dealing
here with two elements.
I mean, first of all,
we have plaster molds
of arguably one of the
best center fielders
in the history of baseball.
And then the second element we
have is the actual autograph.
It's actually personalized
to your uncle,
"Your pal, Joe DiMaggio."
OK.
So I mean, these are
obviously, without a doubt,
a one-of-a-kind
piece here, and there
is no shortage of
people collecting
Joe DiMaggio items out there.
Plus, his feet were a
big part of his success.
Uh, compared to
other DiMaggio items,
I would put the value at
around $3,000 to $5,000 bucks.
COREY: Well, Jeremy, I
appreciate you coming down,
man.
- Absolutely, Corey.
Good to see you, Chum.
- All right.
See you, man.
- Good luck to you.
Great.
Thank you.
You bet.
The value of this item is really
tricky since it's not only
a one-of-a-kind item, but it's
a very unique item in the fact
that it's a plaster
mold, which is something
that collectors never ask for.
COREY: So you heard my guy.
He said, you know,
between $3,000 and $5,000.
Not near what you're
actually looking for.
You still interested?
Uh, not at that price, no.
COREY: Um, no matter what I
pay for this, it's speculation.
I'm guessing that
I'm going to be
able to make money
on it one day,
but I really don't
have any idea.
So I mean, for me to make
an offer at this point
is just kind of ludicrous.
You know?
OK.
COREY: All right?
Understood.
Appreciate you
coming down, man.
JOHN: Great.
Thank you.
You know, I have a different
view regarding the value
of the item, but
it is disappointing
that it was substantially
below the price
that we're looking for.